bangladesh's economy has been one of the
fastest growing in the world but in
recent months soaring energy and food
prices have inflated its import bill
forcing the government to seek loans
from global agencies and raise fuel
prices the impact is already been felt
by many here in the capital dhaka
covered van owner mohammed shah jahan is
worried about the future
no one is renting our vans right now
because they cost more
this is really hard on us you can see
all the drivers sitting idle we can't
figure out what the government is doing
sporadic protests are taking place
nearly every day but security forces are
cracking down this is the second time
the government has increased fuel prices
in just about nine months
the government has blamed russia's war
on ukraine for the increase however
economists have won this would led to
higher inflation and forced people to
cut down on their spending
the rise in food prices is becoming a
concern for people with limited earnings
prices for all food items have gone up
since the hike in fuel prices as
everything has to be transported but our
income has not increased accordingly
transport costs have also gone up in
recent days
the bus fare has considerably gone up
and it's hard on us but what can we do
we have to manage hopefully the
government will bring it under control
soon
economists say the impact of more than
50 increase in fuel prices will affect
the poor and fixed income people the
most this
fuel price is going to have an impact
on
various sections of the economy at least
at three levels
firstly through high transport cost
secondly
there will be increased cost to
production and
in the end
these are going to have an impact on the
consumer
bangladesh's economy has barely
recovered from the pandemic while
thousands of families are now at risk of
being poor again because of the sudden
rise in expenses
experts 1 the nation is facing an
uncertain economic future sandvik
choudhary al-jazeera dhaka